Roberto asks what do you feel is a
bigger obstacle to success a lack of
time or lack of katfoe Roberto this is a
tremendous question I think the biggest
obstacle to success is a lack of
optimism that question in itself is the
problem my friend right you're looking
at two things that are both negatives
and guess what both of them are
obstacles when I started winelibrary.com
transformation from my business I had
time I've worked my face off every
minute but we don't have a whole lot of
money in our profit Center so it took
more time right it's just the way it is
today I have more money but boy don't I
have time but neither ever ever will be
an excuse for me and so just a drill
dhis through the throat of the
vaynernation that's right I went that
graphic don't smile d-roc here's the
bottom line I refuse to allow you to get
an answer to that question because both
of them are firmly Square in the excuse
column and I have no patience for that
there will always be problems let's talk
about a million other things that are a
way to stop success the health and
well-being of your family members so it
takes your mind away from execution the
country you live in is government and
political you know concepts at these
moments a la startups in China that I've
invested in that got traction but then
people that were wired into the
government decided to not allow it to
happen and then the startup disappeared
not as easy to be an entrepreneur there
it's still a communist country sorry it
just is and so all these things can be
problems right there's a competitor with
a billion dollars who's also skilled and
punches you in the mouth and knocks you
out in the first round right the world
changing I mean there's just a million
obstacles right the media one bad
coverage of you a moment in time
you know what I think about a lot you
know what I think about a lot let's get
really real this is why we did this show
I always I'm a human being and I always
think about a moment in time what if I
just say the wrong thing at the wrong
time right what if I call out China for
being a communist country in an episode
while I'm on a rant and somebody is
watching doesn't like the way that
tastes and it takes away a business
tunity for me in china in seven years
even though I'm not trying to Zhuang it
just things that I saw what if what if
you know what if what if I look down on
my phone while I'm driving even though
I've really not done that and I hit
somebody and I kill them and that
becomes the story and I like forget
about the story about what you think of
me I will never recover from that
because I killed somebody because I
needed to check a tweet these are
moments in time so there are so many
things that can keep you from being
successful right the people that you
invested in having something bad happen
to them so it slows you down my friends
there are a million reasons why not but
there's one great reason why which is
you've just gotta persevere no matter
what it is it's just the way it is it's
hard being an entrepreneur it's hard
building a business everybody thinks
it's so easy that there's an entitlement
there's a disaster zinging China here
comes my us thing right now there is an
insane generation of 18 to 25 year olds
right now that think they're entitled to
having a business because they saw the
social network movie and everybody's
decided if you're a kid and you know
what tech is because you used Instagram
early on you're entitled to actually
build a business building a business is
hard and you know what makes it really
hard
everything that happens every day of
every moment so you can pick time you
can pick money as the one or two things
that you think stopped you from winning
your game but the truth is there's a
million reasons 99 percent of businesses
go out of business for a reason and that
reason is it's hard and so if you're
watching this show I've got a sense of
who you are and you need to start
creating layers and layers and layers
and layers of skin to be able to get
through because the glamour of being an
entrepreneur the goodness you know you
get very confused by my optimism because
it's my optimism I can't help it it's
just how I roll it's probably one of the
variable 1% reasons why I'm successful
the please don't get it twisted this is
hard every day is hard and if you don't
have the stomach to weather the storm
you will not be successful and by the
way let me throw you a real weird
curveball and that's okay people have to
look themselves in a mirror and
understand if they're number two three
four or five six seven
organization that has differences of
being a number one but maybe that's
where your skill set sets maybe that's
how you make your fortunes and Happiness
and all the things that you're looking
for and so that question got me going a
little bit Steve because it's under the
context of excuses and I will never make
an excuse everything that's a problem
with me everything I don't achieve
everything that's a problem at
vaynermedia and everything is my fault
and I I succumb to that and I respect
that and I actually think that's the way
it should be
and so um no excuses my friends oh crap
wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe